retired general lloyd austin has served
in the u.s military for four decades
rising from west point graduate to
leader of u.s central command
as the leader of u.s forces in iraq
austin oversaw the withdrawal of troops
under the obama biden administration
general austin was a diplomat it was not
an easy task
he built relationships with our iraqi
counterparts
and with our coalition partners austin
said wednesday
as defense secretary he would continue
to work to strengthen coalitions
america is strongest when it works with
his allies
and over the years i've worked hand in
hand with our
diplomatic colleagues and partners
around the globe and witness firsthand
what we're able to accomplish together
biden says austin is a skilled leader
respected by troops and admired for his
integrity
if confirmed he would become the first
black us secretary of defense
leading a military where more than 40
percent of active duty members are of
color
we need his personal experience helping
inform our efforts to ensure that our
armed forces reflect the full strength
and diversity
of our nation that black latino asian
american native american
women men lgbt service members
are treated with dignity and respect
but austin's nomination also brings some
controversy
u.s law calls for a civilian-led
military
requiring top brass to have been out of
uniform for at least
seven years austin has been retired for
four years
which means he'll need a congressional
waiver
jim mattis was the last defense
secretary who got a waiver
but members of congress said then their
action was a one-time
exception now two democratic senators
have already said they will
not approve a waiver for austin and the
retired general may face
tough questions about his recent work
for a defense contractor
somebody will dig up some some dirt of
some kind
real or imaginary and they'll trundle it
out there and this
this becomes a ready bait for those who
don't want to see this particular thing
occur austin says
if confirmed to biden's cabinet he would
approach the job of u.s defense
secretary
from a civilian perspective and surround
himself
with civilian staff but it is congress
he will have to convince heidi joe
castro al jazeera wilmington delaware